good morning believe nation if your
business isn't taking off yet and it's
starting to have an impact on your
confidence as a human being and it's
impacting your self-worth now I'm gonna
share with you an inspiring clip from
Tim Ferriss that I think Wow
so I can totally relate to this I
remember in my first business my
business was everything I put everything
I had into it and when I wasn't getting
results
it took a major toll on myself on my my
self-worth on my confidence and I
remember prior to that anything I had
applied myself to if I knew her if I put
work into it an effort I would see
results and here was putting everything
I had into this business and I wasn't
seeing results and I I started to feel
worthless and useless and then it was
hard to get up and put energy into my
business and so now while I spend a lot
of time on my business I also have other
interests
I'll go salsa dancing and DJing I'll go
snowboarding I'll go camping I'll play
league of Legends and when I've come to
understand this even if I've had a
terrible week for whatever reason
terrible day terrible month in my
business I can turn it around by seeing
growth and learning in those other areas
of my life so if I'm going salsa dancing
I might learn a new move if I'm DJ and I
might put on a new song if I'm playing
League of Legends I might be trying out
a new champion or new strategies if I'm
going camping they might be trying out
how to improve my upside down fire if
I'm going snowboarding I might figure
out how to how do I learn new tricks and
jumps there's always something new that
I can learn and improve on and when I
make those goals when I see learning and
progress that gives me fuel and energy
that I can take back to my business
because I may not have seen growth and
energy there so for those of you
watching I'd love to know what other
passions and interests and hobbies you
have that what things aren't going
really that well in your business you're
able to do those things and I'd gives
you the energy and life force back that
you can go and pour that back into your
company so leave a comment below let me
know what those activities are I'm
really curious to hear from you thank
you for watching continue to believe
have an amazing day and I'll see you
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso